Tenemos la desigualdad, ésta de aquí,
que es 2/3 mayor que
-4y menos 8 con 1/3.
Ahora lo primero
que quiero hacer aquí es convertir,
este número mixto
que es realmente molesto,
me incomoda muchísimo,
de hecho es es difícil lidiar con el matemáticamente,
así que vamos a convertir esto.
Aquí tenemos
8 1/3
no es otra cosa más
que algo que va a llevar en el denominador un 3
y luego hacemos,
3 por 8 = 24 más 1 son 25
entonces, podemos sustituir
en esta desigualdad y tenemos...
2/3
es mayor que
-4y menos 25/3
Y ahora lo que no me gusta tampoco
es tener
fracciones en esta desigualdad,
entonces lo que tengo que hacer es
multiplicar por algún número
que me quite todas las fracciones
y el primero que
por ejemplo se me ocurre es 3
entonces, si yo multiplico
en ambos lados por 3,
por ejemplo puedo ponerlo
de esta forma,
en realidad la desigualdad
no está cambiando ¿verdad?
multiplico por lo mismo
y además debo remarcar
que multiplico por un número positivo,
si yo multiplicará por algo negativo
entonces la desigualdad cambia,
se cambia de sentido
¿verdad?
sería un menor que es
si multiplicó
por cualquier número negativo
puede ser -1,  -1/2,
¿Qué se yo?
Pero en este caso no es así,
porque es positivo.
Entonces esto lo que me hace,
va a simplificar la desigualdad
y vamos a tener que 2
es mayor que...
y si  aquí distribuimos es -12y
menos 25
¿verdad?
3 veces 25/3 es -25,
y ahora,
¿qué pasa si yo sumo,
si yo sumo de ambos lados 25
para quitar este de aquí, verdad?
Sumo 25 de ambos lados
sumo 25
¿y del lado izquierdo qué me queda?
Lo que me queda es
25 más 2 son 27,
y esto debe ser mayor que -12y
y estos ya se cancelaron
¿verdad?
Entonces ahora sí tengo
27 mayor que -12y
y para despejar la"y"
pues tengo que dividir
entre -12
¿verdad?
y el detalle es que
estoy dividiendo entre -12
o puedes verlo como que estamos multiplicando
por 1 entre -12 ¿verdad?
-1/12
entonces, lo que vamos a tener
es 27 sobre -12
y aquí incluso...
déjenme ponerlo con otro color,
como multiplicados por algo negativo
o dividimos por algo negativo,
el signo de la desigualdad se voltea
Ok,
y acá me queda -12y sobre -12,
y esto bueno pues podemos simplificarlo
¿verdad?
En tanto el numerador
como el denominador tienen 1/3
entonces esto será menos,
si sacamos tercera parte de esto es 9,
sobre tercera parte de 12 es 4
que es menor que nuestra "y"
Entonces aquí,
ya tenemos el resultado,
digamos en realidad lo podemos
poner de la siguiente forma
como que "y" es más grande
que -9/4,
simplemente fue fue cambiándolos,
y si...
si se te dificulta verlo de esta forma,
puedes
decir que "y" es más grande,
por ejemplo, si lo pasamos a
a fracción mixta ¿verdad?
esto es menos
¿cuántos cuartos tenemos aquí?
Pues tenemos dos...
perdón
¿Cuántos enteros tenemos?
Dos enteros y 1/4
¿verdad?
4 por 2 son 8 y 1 = 9
ahí está , ahora
¿qué pasaría si yo quiero graficarlo?
Pues pintemos nuestra
recta real,
por ejemplo,
puede ser que aquí anda el 0
acá anda -1,
el -2,
aquí estará el -3
y así en adelante
¿verdad?
Entonces hay que ubicar
el -2 enteros 1/4,
bueno, pues ese,
déjenme ponerlo con este color
ese andará como por aquí
y hay que ponerlo con un circulito vacío,
porque no lo estamos incluyendo,
no estamos suponiendo
que es también igual.
Entonces,
todo esto de aquí a la derecha
todos estos "y"
tomamos...
tomamos todo lo que sea más grande
que este número que es -2 1/4
nos tomamos
todo lo que sea más grande,
y todas esas "y" son válidas...
Son "y" que van a satisfacer
la desigualdad.